[Musik]
die Nachrichten des Tages heute mit
Mitri Sirin schönen guten Abend die
wichtigsten Nachrichten in den nächsten
20 Minuten und Sport mit Christian Otto
gehört dazu heute mal ohne Fußball guten
Abend dann geht's jetzt los mit dem
Überblick für
Sie nächste Geduldsprobe für Pendler ein
Warnstreik der Bus U-Bahn und
Straßenbahnfahrer führt in fast allen
Bundesländern zum stillst
israel will Offensive ausweiten Soldaten
sollen auch nach rafach im Süden des
gasastreifens
vorstoßen mehr lesen schreiben rechnen
ein Milliarden Förderprogramm soll
benachteiligten Schülerinnen und
Schülern bessere Startchancen
ermöglichen ja es war wieder ein Tag an
dem die Mobilität in Deutschland stark
ausgebremst wurde Busse u oder
Straßenbahnen fuhren fast überall nicht
wegen des wer die Warnstreiks alle
Bundesländer außer Bayern waren
betroffen insgesamt rund 80 Städte und
40 Landkreise und es wird zwar teils
auch um höhere Löhne gerungen vor allem
geht's aber um Arbeitsbedingungen
weniger Wochenstunden längere Ruhezeiten
und mehr Urlaub sollen den Beruf nach
Meinung der Gewerkschaften attraktiver
machen Peter
Tyson Streit bei den U-Bahnen in
Düsseldorf Stillstand auch auf Hamburgs
Gleisen und im rheinmingebiet bewegt
sich ein Bus leihragende vor allem
Schüler und Pendler jetzt hier die
Straßenbahn nicht fährt damit habe ich
nicht gerechnet und dann passt alles
nicht und ich komme jedes Mal zu spät
kein Verständnis nee ich bin heute
morgen zu Fuß vom Hotel her gelaufen
sind ca 3 km also machbar ich find nicht
in Ordnung dass auf ja auf dem Rücken
der Leute die halt morgens zur Arbeit
müssen auszutragen also ich muss jetzt
in die Klinik und komme nicht hin die
wenigen die hier heute mit dem Bus
fahren können sind die Busfahrer selbst
mehrere tausend sind zur zentralen
Kundgebung nach Mainz gekommen es geht
ihnen vor allem um ihre
Arbeitsbedingungen wie z.B kürzere
Schichten oder längere Pausen dass
vielleicht auch die ganzen
verkehrsbetreebe das realisieren dass
die dass die Fahrer alles zusammen
stehen und dass ich da was ändern muss
weil so kann es definitiv nicht
weitergehen wenn sich die Bedingungen
nicht verbessern dann sei die ganze
Verkehrswende in Gefahr weil niemand
mehr Bus oder Straßenbahnfahrer werden
möchte meint die Gewerkschaft allein in
den nächsten 7 Jahren gehen etwa 50% der
Kolleginnen und in Rente das heißt wir
haben ein echtes Problem auch übrigens
für die Fahrgäste und deswegen steht
Entlastung ganz oben doch die Kommunen
shind sich oft gar nicht imstande den
Forderungen nachzugeben etwa nach
kürzerer Arbeitszeit werdi hat uns jetzt
in Hessen
ein der umfangreichsten
Forderungskataloge in ganz Deutschland
auf den Tisch gelegt unter anderem die
35 Stundenwoche bei vollem Lohnausgleich
das verschärft aber quasi auch noch mal
den
Fachkräftemangel 90.000 Beschäftigte
hatte werdi zum Streik aufgerufen der
Druck auf die Arbeitgeber
wächst im Tarifkonflikt geht's der
Gewerkschaft werdi vor allem auch um
eine Reduzierung der Arbeitszeiten und
das könnte auch attraktiv auf möglichen
nachwuchswirken der an allen Ecken und
Enden fehlt in Zeiten von
Fachkräftemangel und einer immer älter
werdenden Belegschaft sehen sich viele
Bahn und Busfahrer an der
Belastungsgrenze aus Brandenburg Jan
Meer Steffen Kraus mag seinen Job seit
dre Jahrzehnten fährt er Bus in der
brandenburgischen Landeshauptstadt doch
die Arbeit wird immer schwerer für ihn
und seine Kollegen durch Überstunden
Wochenendarbeit schlecht bezahlte
Schichten die bis zu 13 Stunden dauern
können na wenn ich anfange als Busfahrer
verdiene ich so 2600 € brutto können
sich vorstellen wir fahren 365 Tage 24
Stunden hier in Potzdam wir haben
Nachtlinien ist schon nicht sehr
viel zuk kommt an manchen Tagen arbeiten
sie jeweils einige Stunden morgens und
nachmittags für die freie Zeit
dazwischen erhalten Sie nur ein Endgeld
von 2 € immer mehr Fahrgäste die Dienste
werden immer länger die Wendezeit immer
kürzer es wird ja immer mehr
Effektivität verlangt von uns ja und
irgendwann muss auch mal der Arbeitgeber
sich Hal danach drehen weil der Personal
Mangel der bei uns Herstell muss
irgendwoher kommen ja der kommt ja nicht
von unungefäh sondern der kommt daher
weil der Job nicht mehr attraktiv ist
Steffen Kraus ist 52 Jahre alt will bis
zur Rente arbeiten mit Sorge beobachtet
er dass es immer schwieriger wird
Nachwuchs zu finden ohne mehr Gehalt
wird das so bleiben das ist ein schöner
Job mir macht da heute noch Spaß also
und da wollen wir auch wieder hin dass
die Leute sagen Mensch Busfahren ist do
was feinet er und seine Kollegen sind
bereit noch einmal für ihre Forderungen
auf die Straße zu gehen ab morgen früh
werden sie aber dafür sorgen dass Busse
und Bahnen wieder wie gewohnt durch
potzdamrollen der Bundesrat hat mehrere
Vorhaben der der Ampelkoalition
gebilligt darunter neue abschieberegeln
und die Möglichkeit zur schnelleren
Einbürgerung auch die elektronische
Patientenakte winkte die Länderkammer
durch zuvor hatte der Bundestag den
Haushalt verabschiedet mit
veranschlagten 39 Milliarden Euro neuer
Schulden wird die Schuldenbremse wieder
eingehalten beschlossen auch der
umstrittene Abbau von Steuerentlastungen
beim Agrardiesel umgesetzt werden kann
das aber noch nicht weil die
unionsgeführten Länder im Bundesrat das
dafür notwendige Gesetz erst einmal
ausbremsen und warum das so ist das
wollen wir jetzt Diana Zimmermann in
Berlin Fragen Diana warum blockiert die
Union etwa die Regelung zum
Agrardiesel weil sie es konnte die Union
hat durch ein etwas ungewöhnliches
Vorgehen dafür gesorgt dass das
haushaltsfinanzierungsgesetz heute nicht
auf der Tagesordnung für den Bundesrat
erschienen ist damit ist es ihr gelungen
dass für die Ampel
wundepunkt Thema das Wunde Thema
Haushalt noch ein wenig länger gedrückt
zu halten gleichzeitig hat die Union
sich heute im Bundestag noch einmal für
den Agrardiesel stark gemacht und so an
die Seite der Bauern gestellt die haben
jetzt auch schon angekündigt dass sie
bis zur für den 22 März geplanten
Verabschiedung des Gesetzes
noch weiter für den Agrar Diesel kämpfen
wollen nun ist die haushaltswoche zu
Ende zwischen Ampel und Union scheint
das Tischtuch endgültig zerschnitten wie
wie schätzt du das ein ja das war eine
Woche in der es wirklich hochh herging
im Bundestag der Kanzler hat den
Oppositionsführer eine Mimose genannt
der wiederum hat dem Kanzler mitgeteilt
dass er sich künftige Angebote zur
Zusammenarbeit sparen könnte das Ganze
zeigt eben dass dieses Gezerre um den
Haushalt der Ampel wirklich an die
Nerven gegangen ist und an die Substanz
und dass die Union das gut für sich zu
nutzen wusste weitere Angriffsflächen
werden sich bald bieten denn schon bald
geht es um den Haushalt 2025 vielen Dank
für die Einschätzung Diana nach
Berlin der Breite gesellschaftliche
Protest gegen Rechtsextremismus der geht
weiter am Wochenende sind wieder viele
Kundgebungen geplant Auftakt heute unter
anderem in Kiel laut Polizei
versammelten sich dort etwa
4800 Menschen in der Innenstadt und
zogen danach durch die Straßen
aufgerufen dazu hatten der Deutsche
Gewerkschaftsbund Fridays for future und
andere
Organisation zu den landesweiten Demos
gibt's auch frische ZF
politbarometerzahlen Matthias vonof ist
bei uns guten Abend und Matthias hallo
guten Abend wie fällt das Echo zu den
Protesten aus na wir sehen da eine sehr
klare Mehrheit die für die
Demonstrationen ist 79% sagen die Demos
sind gut nicht gut 16% das wird die AFD
Schwächen erwarten
38% Stärken glauben 18%. das hat keine
Auswirkungen
39%. wir haben gefragt ist die AFD eine
Gefahr für die Demokratie 72% der
Befragten im Politbarometer sagen ja sie
ist eine Gefahr aber nur 41% finden die
Partei sollte verboten werden eine
Mehrheit von
53% ist gegen ein Verbot Matthias dann
kommen wir zur Sonntagsfrage wie sieht's
da aus in unruhiger Zeit einiges an
Bewegung wenn am nächsten Sonntag
Bundestagswahl wäre kenme die SPD auf
15% + 2 CDU CSU
31% grüne 13 1 FDP weiter 4% AFD 19 -3
linke 3 freie Wähler 3 beide -1
bündniswagenknecht 6% + 2 das BSW sogar
mit Potenzial für mehr bei der nächsten
Bundestagswahl würde ich das Bündnis
Wagenknecht sicher oder wahrscheinlich
wählen sagen 19% darunter 41% der AFD
Anhänger die neue Partei also wird auch
als
protestalternative zur AFD gesehen
interessante Zahlen vielen Dank Matthias
und wie immer gibt's das gesamte ZDF
Politbarometer ab 22 Uhr im heute
journal oder aber jederzeit online auf
ZDF heute oder in unserer App auch dort
wieder mit der Frage nach den zehn
wichtigsten
Politikern nach langem Ringen haben sich
die ampelfraktionen über letzte Details
zur teillegalisierung von Cannabis
geeinigt das Gesetz soll jetzt noch in
diesem Monat verabschiedet werden und
könnte dann im April in Kraft treten
Eigenanbau und Besitz begrenzter Mengen
der Droge wäre dann für Erwachsene
erlaubt einige SPD Abgeordnete lehnen
das Gesetz allerdings weiter ab und
wollen dagegen
stimmen noch immer entscheidet die
soziale Herkunft über den Bildungserfolg
bei Kindern und Jugendlichen das zeigen
mehrere Studien mit dem
stschancenprogramm will die Regierung
jetzt gegensteuern
über 10 Jahre sollen 20 Milliarden Euro
in rund 4000 Schulen und Berufsschulen
investiert werden profitieren könnten
davon rund eine Million Schüler zum
Vergleich insgesamt gibt's knapp 11
Millionen Schüler in Deutschland wi
heser ein sozialer Brennpunkt in Kiel
Stadtteil Wellingdorf mittendrin die
Theodor Storm Gemeinschaftsschule 650
Schülerinnen und Schüler besuchen Sie
wir haben fast 100% Kinder die zu Hause
nicht Deutsch sprechen und der zweite
Faktor ist das Thema Armut 60% unserer
Familien leben im staatlichen
transferbezug und die anderen 40% Leben
so ganz knapp da drüber so dass wir also
an der Schule das große Problem haben
dass wir das kompensieren müssen damit
das gelingen kann bekommt die Schule vom
Land Schleswig Holstein seit 2019
finanzielle Unterstützung für mehr
Lehrkräfte mehr Schulstunden mehr Hilfe
für auffällige
ollen Bund und Länder nun zusammenlegen
es geht um 20 Milliarden Euro in 10
Jahren für etwa 4000 Schulen mit einem
hohen Anteil an sozial benachteiligten
Schülerinnen und Schüler und das hat es
so noch nie gegeben es soll mehr
Unterrichtsentwicklung nach Bedarf geben
wenn es z.B in Mathe harert mehr Mathe
mehr multiprofessionelle Teams das heißt
statt einer Lehrkraft mehrere plus
Experten je nach Herausforderung die
Ausstattung soll besser werden
kreativlabors Sportmöglichkeiten
ruhecken wir haben Schulen die
auseinander fallallen wir haben
Lehrkräfte die fehlen wir
Digitalisierung die ausbleibt natürlich
ist an dieses Programm schön und es ist
ein guter erster Schritt aber es reicht
noch lange nicht aus hier in Kiel hofft
man auf eine langfristige Förderung denn
das wissen sie Chancengerechtigkeit ist
ein großes Wort und ein langer
Weg zum Krieg im Nahen Osten da will
Israel seine Offensive bis ganz in den
Süden des Gazastreifens auswe
direkt nach dem Terrorangriff der Hamas
am 7 Oktober hatte die Armee vor allem
den Norden des dichtbesiedelten Gebietes
angegriffen hunderttausende
Palästinenser flüchteten dann Richtung
Süden aber auch die Kämpfe verlagerten
sich zuletzt stand hananjunis im
Mittelpunkt jetzt nimmt Israel rafach
ins visesier dort leben inzwischen
geschätzt 1,3 Millionen Menschen Stefan
Gareis auf dem Weg zur
Frischwasserstation mittenurch Rach
jeden Tag kommt Jahja hierher für sich
und seine Familie ganz aus dem Norden
sind sie geflohen aus Angst um ihr
Leben das Wasser hier ist nicht wirklich
sauber eigentlich sollten wir es nicht
nutzen eine Alternative gibt es aber
nicht im völlig überlaufenen rafach
breiten sich Krankheiten aus auch Corona
wird wieder zum Problem und jetzt die
Angst vor den Angriffen der israelischen
Armee wohin wollen Sie dass wir gehen es
gibt keinen Ort mehr an den wir gehen
können wir werden in rafach sterben es
ist unmöglich hier
rauszukommen ich sage ihnen dass wir die
Mission in chanunes abschließen und dann
nach rafach Zehen werden wir werden dort
jeden Terroristen eliminieren jeden der
versucht uns
anzugreifen die Worte des israelischen
Verteidigungsministers sind eindeutig
auch der südlichste Punkt in Gaza ist
nicht mehr sicher mehr als 1,3 Millionen
Zivilisten sollen sich in dem Gebiet
befinden etwa die Hälfte von Gazas
Gesamtbevölkerung die meisten leben in
professorischen Unterkünften Zelten oder
im Freien rafach ist ein Ort der
Verzweiflung und wir haben Angst vor dem
was als nächstes
kommt wo also sollen die Menschen noch
hin in Gaza gibt es offenbar keinen
sicheren Ort
mehr harter Schnitt jetzt gute Nachricht
für Verbraucher Handys Staubsauger oder
Waschmaschinen sollen in EU-Ländern bald
t werden müssen wenn der Kunde es
verlangt euunterhändler haben das
sogenannte Recht auf Reparatur auf den
Weg gebracht damit dürften in Zukunft
Millionen Tonnen weniger Elektroschrott
anfallen außerdem soll es einfacher und
günstiger werden mehr von janfederich
Fischer Manfred möig freut sich statt
sein defektes Smartphone wegzuwerfen und
ein neues kaufen zu müssen kann er sein
Gerät reparieren lassen unkompliziert
und kostenlos im repaircaff in tübing
einmal im Monat hier eine Gruppe von IT
dafür dass defekte Geräte ein zweites
Leben bekommen happy wenn sie herkommen
und ihre Sachen eventuell repariert
bekommen beim letzten repair caff hab
wir hab wir dreiviertel der Artikel
reparieren können reparieren statt
wegwerfen das soll auch europaweit
Standard werden und so hat sich die EU
in der Nacht auf ein Recht auf Reparatur
verständigt heißt konkret auf Wunsch
müssen Hersteller künftig bestimmte
Alltagsgegenstände reparieren darunter
etwa waschm schinen Kühlschränke oder
Smartphones und Information über
Bauteile und Reparaturen sollen
einfacher geteilt werden das Ziel
lästige Reparaturen attraktiver machen
und Elektroschrott vermeiden für die
Verbraucherinnen und Verbraucher
verbessert sich dass sie ein Recht auf
Reparatur haben mit dem Recht auf
Reparatur zwingen wir gewissermaßen die
Hersteller dazu Ersatzteile zur
Verfügung zu stellen die Elektrobranche
reagiert gelassen die
Verbraucherzentrale hingegen fordert
schon jetzt eine Verschärfung da
wünschen wir uns natürlich mehr weil
wieso sollen Möbel oder Kaffeemaschinen
nicht auch repariert werden müssen bis
das EU-Gesetz tatsächlich umgesetzt wird
kann es noch länger dauern im repaircaff
wollen sie aber nicht mehr warten und
sagen der Wegwerfmentalität schon jetzt
den Kampf
an jetzt aus aktuellem Anlass zu zwei
besonders kreativen Köpfen da wäre zum
einen Alfred Hitchcock der ur für
menschliche Urängste und der andere er
hier Salvador D Maler surrialist und
bekannt für seine gestochen scharfen
Traumbilder jenseits der Realität in
seinem Film Spellbound von 1945 wollte
Hitchcock unter anderem einen Albtraum
auf die Leinwand bringen und dachte
dabei sofort an Dali ihre einmalige
Zusammenarbeit perfekter Stoff für eine
Ausstellung in München J
sonnewald es ist als würde man sich in
ein syrialen Traumwelt bewegen gläserne
Augen die einen verfolgen bizarre
Skulpturen des Künstlers Salvador D
bevölkern die Bühne der alten
filharmonie in München diese Ausstellung
feiert die Zusammenarbeit zwischen dem
spanischen syrialisten und dem
britischen Filmemacher Alfred Hitchcock
im psychorill Spellbound von
1945 zwei Genies ihres Faches die sich
zusammengetan haben um etwas gemeinsam
zu schaffen und beide waren auch durch
diese Zusammenarbeit inspiriert sie
haben miteinander gearbeitet das ist
nicht so dass ein Entwurf gleich die
Szene ergeben hat sondern das war ein
Prozess hitchkock und D inszenierten die
inzwischen zum Kult gewordene
Traumsequenz im Oscar premierten
Spellbound mit Ingrid Bergmann und
Gregory P in den Hauptrollen schließlich
hatten beide Meister ein fäbel für
Psychoanalyse Träume und
Paranoia dargestellt wurden doch er
wollte dass sie scharf und präzise sind
und D war ein Meister der Klarheit
deshalb wollte Hitchcock mit
Zusammenarbeiten mit VR Brillen können
Besucher Eintauchen in die
dreidimensionale Traumsequenz und zu
einem virtuellen Sigmund freut Traum
oder Realität damit spielten Salvador D
und Alfred Hitchcock damit spielt auch
diese Ausstellung in München Träume
machen Angst denn sie sind immer
real so wir tauchen jetzt in den Sport
ein das ist ein gutes Stichwort in DOA
haben die Schwimmweltmeisterschaften
begonnen Christin noch ohne Medaillen
für die Deutschen aber knapp verpasst
die ersten zwei Entscheidungen fielen im
Kunst und Turmspringen Platz 4 für Jette
Müller vom 1 m Brett ebenso vierte wurde
die deutsche Mix teammannschaft Linna
Henschel und Moritz Wesemann hatten das
deutsche mixteam zur Halbzeit im Rennen
um die Medaillen gehalten vom 3 mer
Brett lieferten sie drei gute Sprünge ab
und lagen auf dem Bronzerang die
Deutschen im vergangenen Jahr WM dritte
mussten vom Turm nachlegen doch Elena
Wassen und Timo batel gelang das nicht
ganz perfekt ihr synchronsprung nicht
gut genug um erneut eine Medaille zu
gewinnen Platz 4 zum Auftakt die erste
Goldmedaille ging an die Briten vor
Mexiko und
Australien Sieg und Niederlage zu Beginn
der Davis Cup Qualifikation für die
Deutschen Tennisspieler in Ungarn in
Abwesenheit des Erkrankten Alexander SF
gewinnt zunächst Dominik Köpfer sein
Einzel danach verliert aber Jan Lennard
struf sein Match der Vorhandball von Jan
Lenard Struff zu lange sein Gegner
Marton fuschkoovc hat das erste Break
geschafft der Ungar die Nummer 82 der
Welt bringt anschließend auch seinen
Aufschlag durch zum Satzgewinn 6:3 ein
Netzroller ist es der Struff irritiert
und fuschkoovc beim Stande von 5 Z5 im
zweiten Satz ein Break beschert
Aufschlag und Chance auf den Match
Gewinn für den starken
Ungarn der lässt sich den Sieg nicht
mehr nehmen 6:3 und 7 Z5 Ungarn gleicht
aus nach dem ersten Tag Struff wird
seiner Favoritenrolle nicht gerecht
bechlings zu em Silber RAS skeleton
Olympiasiegerin Hanna Neise aus
Winterberg im lettischen Eiskanal von
Sigulda schneller als die 33jährige war
die belgerin Kim meilemannz bei den
Männern holte Felix Kaisinger Bronze und
im Zweierbob Weltcup der Frauen wurde
sogar ein deutscher dreifach tririumph
bejubelt Kim kaliki siegt mit ihrer
Anschieberin Leonie fiebich vor den Duos
mit Laura Nolte und Lisa buckwitz an den
lenksseilen es ist nach Innsbruck
eagless bereits der zweite dreifach
Erfolg in diesem Winter Klasse Frauen
vielen Dank Christin ja jetzt zu einem
besonderen Geburtstagskind das ziemlich
viele Kinderzimmer bevölkert die
Playmobil Figur vor 50 Jahren
sie auf den Markt thematisch spren die
Cowboys Polizisten und Lockführer damals
zunächst vor allem Jungs
an aussteigen abfahren
über die Jahre ist Playmobil
vielfältiger geworden bis hin zu den
Village People oder
Asterix ausgenommen sind die Figuren
übrigens oder ausgekommen immer ohne
ohen außer er hier misock von Star
Trek habe ich auch nichtusst habe ich
heute erst erfahren so es bleibt
vergleichsweise mild aber trüb wo sie
mit Sonne wo er mit Regen rechnen
sollten gleich von Katja horneffer das
heute journal heute um 22 Uhr mit
Marietta Slomka schönen Start ins
Wochenende und bis
[Musik]
morgen guten Abend hier sehen Sie die
baren die Linien gleichen Luftdrucks wo
die gedrängt sind weh der Wind besonders
kräftig sie sehen aber auch dass bis
morgen Abend Wolken und Regen von
Nordwest nach Südost über Deutschland
hinwegziehen einige profitieren
allerdings auch von dem hochfrank das
bringt ruhiges Winterwetter mit und
Sonnenschein das merken sie vor allen
Dingen in den Alpen am Wochenende jetzt
hier am Alpenrand wird es in der Nacht
nämlich auch schon meist klar sein
einige Nebelfelder bilden sich in der
Mitte und über den Norden ziehen
Regenwolken hinweg bei Westwind die
Temperaturen der Nacht sinken auf 9 bis
1° und liegen dann morgen zwischen 7 und
12° dabei wird es im Münsterland und am
niederrein am mildesten das wird ein
meist trüb Samstag mit etwas Regen oder
Nieselregen freundlicher sieht's aus vom
Berch des gardenerland bis zum oberrein
da scheint die Sonne zum Teil strahlend
einige Sonnenstrahlen werden sie
allerdings auch an den Küsten von Nord
und Ostsee zu Gesicht bekommen am
Sonntag regnet es dann eher noch
kräftiger als am Samstag und die neue
Woche startet aus gesprochen mild mit
Höchsttemperaturen von 6 bis
15° schönes Wochenende